واوكرانيا لنشهد حربا طاحنة لا
تبقي ولا تذر بين موسكو وبكين
لحل البرلمان والصدر يقولها
للاطار التنسيقي سننتصر عليكم
اما في العراق فقد اكد القضاء
العراقي انه لا يمتلك الصلاحية
روسية مقطع فيديو يستعرض مزايا
روسيا ويدعو الاوروبيين للجوء
واشنطن ايران على بعد اسابيع من
امتلاك ما يكفي من المواد
يونيو الماضي. اعلنت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية سيطرة قواتها
القوات الاوكرانية على مواقع
روسية بغاذفات متعددة في منطقة
وتفكك مجلس القيادة الرئاسي. فما
الذي تريده الامارات من اليمن
القتلى في صفوف جيش الشرعية
اليمنية المدعومة من السعودية.
اليها وذلك في اطار العقوبات
التي فرضتها حكومات على موسكو
وزارة الري السودانية بانها
ستتخذ الاجراءات اللازمة اذا هدد
من جديد تطفو قضية سد النهضة
الاثيوبي على السطح. حيث اعلنت
الانشطارية لصنع قنبلة نووية.
شاركت شرطة مدينة بولاية تنس
برمته? الاحداث والتطورات? نشر
الجيش الاوكراني مشاهد تظهر هجوم
نظمت وزارة الدفاع الروسية جولة
لمنح الجنسية الروسية لسكان
دخلت الامارات اليمن تحت ذريعة
محاربة الحوثيين وبعد ان وصلت
تاركة للحوثيين في مدرجات
المشجعين. وتستمر المعارك بين
وسنحكم. هل ستصدق نبوءات
وتحليلات صدقت في حرب روسيا
ليختتم المقطع بجملة افقدت
الاوروبيين اعصابهم وهي الشتاء
الرئاسية القادمة والتي ستكون في
الفين واربعة وعشرين عبث
القانون الثاني عرقلة العدالة
والعقوبة القصوى لذلك هي السجن
تسريب معلومات استخباراتية
اسرائيلية لروسيا. ايضا سرب صورة
الرياح بما لا تشتهي السفن. فبعد
ان اقتحم الاف بي اي منزل ترامب
عشر عن وجود غواصتين نوويتين
قبالة سوا لكوريا الشمالي.
بعد احتلال جزوره وموانئه? الم
تكتفي بذلك وتريد تدمير البلد
اعظم. فهل هذا السقوط كف باضفاء
امل ترامب بترشحه للانتخابات
اسرائيلية كانت تقل مستوطنين في
حي المغاربة بالقدس المحتلة الى
عملية اطلاق نار من مسلح تسبب
بسقوط قتلى وجرحى بينهم ثلاثة
الري في المشروعات الزراعية
الخاصة بالسودان. تعرضت حافلة
يواجه عقوبات كبيرة قد تصل الى
السجن ثلاثين عاما في حال
ادانته. الاول انتهاك قانون
التجسس بجمع معلومات الدفاع او
ملء سد النهضة سلامة خزان
الروصيرص وادى الى التأثير على
العشرات من عناصرها ابنة ضابط
متوفى الى روضة الاطفال في يومها
الفين وخمسمائة مواطن اوكراني
تلقوا جوازات سفر روسية منذ
الارهاب وانتم السب قلنا لها
قولا وفعلا. ترامب في ورطة. بهذا
في سوريا دون التفريق بين
المواطن والطرف العسكري وراح
الكثير من الضحايا. وامريكا قتلت
اكثر من مليون عراقي والملايين
محافظة شبوة اليمنية. وقد خلف
القصف الاماراتي العشرات من
قوات المجلس الانتقالي التابع
للامارات والقوات الحكومية في
لتقصف القوات الموالية للتحالف
السعودي باكثر من ثلاثين غارة
قبل المتحدة ستدمر العلاقات
الثنائية. هنا سنقول كلمة الحق
الامل لديه بالعودة بالمعركة
الانتخابية القادمة ولكن تجري
في اوروبا والولايات المتحدة
وتصنيف روسيا كدولة راعية
تمكنت من تحديد المكان الذي
تستهدف منه المحطة وهو قرية
ستستهدف الجنود الروس الذين
يطلقون النار على منشأة النووية
النووية. اذ اعلن الطرف الروسي
عن قصف اوكراني جديد لمحطة
على نسخة منها هي ابلاغ الرئيس
الفلبيني في ابريل الفين وسبعة
صواريخ الحوثيين الى دبي هي
اليوم تستغل الهدنة في اليمن
اماراتي. كما يقول المثل المصري
لتحسب موسى يطلع فرعون بعد ان
لمدة عشرين سنة. ومن هذه
المعلومات التي حصلت البي بي سي
الاوكرانية ان القوات الروسية
جددت قصفها لمحطة زابروتش. وانها
ملامحها شيئا فشيئا. فثمة اطراف
تخشى وقوعها واخرى ترى فيها حلا
مثاليا لمعالجة الازمة السورية.
برأيكم هل ستتم هذه المصالحة
الروسية لسد الفراغ العسكري هناك
فقد تذهب هذه القوات الروسية الى
اوكرانيا اي بكل اختصار يجب وضع
قوات تركية بدلا من القوات
ليعود بشار الاسد الى الواجهة من
جديد? دخان الحرب. والملقب
زبروتشا للطاقة النووية جنوبي
اوكرانيا لترد المخابرات العامة
التنبؤات والتحليلات السياسية
وعلى رأسها حرب روسيا واوكرانيا
بالثعلب العجوز هو وزير امريكي
سابق تحققت له الكثير من
العسكرية شريطة التنسيق المباشر
مع النظام السوري. ليعود اعتباره
بحالة حرجة بحسب وسائل اعلان
كيان الاحتلال. نشرت وسائل اعلام
قادم.
قاسية فمن الصعب ان تلعب بالبيض
والحجر في الوقت ذاته. ليتحرك
الاول تكريما لوالدها. ماذا عن
اطفال غزة وسوريا واليمن والعراق
منصة اطلاق صواريخ امريكية الصنع
ومستودعا للذخيرة بمدينة باقليم
بصورة كلية على منطقة بيسكي
المحاذية لمطار الدولي وتدميرها
الامريكية عبر صفحتها الموثقة
على فيسبوك مقطعا مصورا يظهر
الاوكرانية وقالت دائرة الهجرة
في قسم شرطة برديانسك ان نحو
ونحن نعلم انها ستزعج الكثير.
روسيا استخدمت البراميل المتفجرة
للارهاب. لترد موسكو وتحذر من ان
اي مصادرة محتملة لاصول روسية من
الشكل يخرج ترامب من البيت
الابيض بعد فوز بايدن ليتجدد
ايران بانها فشلت ولم تستطع
اطلاق قمر صناعي. وما خفي كان
متباهيا بقوته بحسب نص المكالمة
التي نشرتها الفلبين حينها وكذلك
ليقدم رئيس الحكومة اليمني وهو
ما يهدد بانهيار الهدنة الاممية
لقاعدة ايرانية ليرفقها بتغريدته
في موقع تويتر وسخر حينها من
فوديان. هنا رئيس الاوكراني
زيلينسكي يصرح ان اوكرانيا
المفترض ان يؤدي اليه فلتستعدوا
لذلك. لنعد الى قنبلة زبروتشا
جزئيا في المنطقة دون اي مفهوم
لكيفية نهاية هذا. او ما الذي من
اذ تنبأ بها قبل خمس سنوات. ها
هو اليوم يظهر من جديد ليقول نحن
يعطي تركيا امتيازات خاصة لتخاطر
انقرة بتعزيز علاقاتها مع موسكو
من العقوبات الغربية. ويعلن عن
استقبال جميع الشركات الروسية
في افغانستان وفيتنام وغيرها.
فلماذا تنزعجون من هذه الكلمة
ليعلن الغرب عن خيانة مشروعة من
الطرف التركي وتهديدات بعقوبات
نقلها او فقدها والعقوبة القصوى
لخرقه هي السجن لعشر سنوات.
التي طالتها العقوبات الغربية
هنا اختراق روسي ومخاطره تركية
الاعتبار. تحالف تكتيكي واضح بين
الكرملين وحفيد ارطغرل. فنحن
المتحدة تؤكد جديتها حيث اعلنت
انها ستجري عمليات عبور بحرية
جوا وبحرا في المضيق الذي يفصل
الجزيرة عن الصين. وهنا الولايات
اوكرانيا. المصالحة مع دمشق
سياسة ورغبة لتركيا تتكشف
جنوبي البلاد لتجدد واشنطن
دعواتها لمصادرة الاصول الروسية
على حافة حرب مع روسيا والصين
بشأن القضايا التي انشأناها
اولا ولملئ الفراغ الذي تركته
القوات الروسية اثناء حربها مع
تفصل ايران عن تحقيق حلمها.
والاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر وخلافات
نووية لها علاقة بكوريا
الشمالية. وثلاثة اسابيع فقط
الاعتبار. فبماذا سترد انقرة
ومسؤول امريكي رفيع يتوعد روسيا
اردوجان بفتحه مع بوتين قائلا
نريد حلحلة العقدة السورية. دهاء
الملف السوري وهو الملف الساخن
في الوقت الحالي. اذ باشر
فاعلون يا اصحاب العيون الضيقة
تجاه هذا الاستفزاز? رد
وجوية في مضيق تايوان في
الاسابيع المقبلة. فماذا انتم
الامريكي الى تايبي ليعلن البيت
الابيض ان الولايات المتحدة
نعلم ان بوتين سياسي شيطاني فهو
لا يعطي اكثر مما يأخذ. بوتين
غارة. وهذه هي استفزاز امريكي.
بعد ان وضعت سماعتها السياسية
ستعزز مبادلاتها التجارية مع
تايوان وتؤكد على حق في التحرك
سد النهضة تطفو من جديد. ووعود
عراقية قد تنتهي بكارثة بينما
القيصر هنا اذ حرك احد خيوطه
ليرد عليه سنمرر لك العملية
واشنطن تستفز بكين بزيارة اخرى
لتايوان حيث وصل وفد من الكونجرس
على حساب الناتو ويفتح اردوجان
بوابته الخلفية لروسيا كي تهرب
الطيران الاماراتي يقصف قوات
يمنية حكومية باكثر من ثلاثين
لتقيس نبضات ردة الفعل السياسي
والعسكري من الصين. ها هي اليوم
التنين الصيني من جديد. وهنا
بوتين يطالب من تركيا برد
والصين بمواجهة عسكرية محتملة؟
وترامب معلومات استخباراتية
ويجب على الصين ان تكون هادئة.
بهذا التصريح تستفز امريكا
وواشنطن.
ستمر سفننا الحربية من مضيق
تايوان خلال الاسابيع القادمة